there's always an advantage and a
disadvantage from every position gym
launch is still a big company and still
continues to grow but in the gym
licensing space there's not many people
who can compete with us there and
younger guys would be like well I want
to be in this space too and it's not
fair because you know you have this big
advantage and I was like you have a way
bigger Advantage than I do I was like
cuz if I were in your position I would
go to every single gym owner and be like
you don't want to be with gy launch you
don't want to be with Alex you're just a
number to him with me you're going to
get my personalized attention there is
just some employee down the chain that's
following some process there's always a
position and there's always an advantage
I was like you just have to play the one
you've got and most people just look get
what everyone else's advantages and
don't think which one do I have